hey everybody and welcome to a ball
busting wild ride with stevo danger
aaron his balls have been through it all
and somehow he lived to tell us about it
plus there's quite a bit of ball busting
going on with regards to the new jackass
cast members i'm just gonna throw it out
there but this is a wild ride indeed and
i love danger aaron i mean he's my bro
for life and i want to live for a long
long time and that's why i quit smoking
and i'm happy to tell you that this
episode is brought to you by fume makers
of the best products for quitting
smoking cigarettes vape all of it it's a
one stop shop at breathe fume dot com
slash stevo that's b r e a t h e
f u m dot com slash stevo and what can i
say about quitting smoking i'm just i'm
the
i couldn't be more happy it's my
favorite thing i ever did was quit
smoking it makes people look at you like
you're a loser whether you're vaping or
not and the secret to quitting is to
make sure that you're keeping yourself
busy doing something because that's a
lot of what smoking is it's just like
fidgety like i just need to be doing
something and the people at fume know
that well so they make these
these inhalers that don't have any smoke
no vape no nicotine just purely natural
ingredients with oils that are proven to
help reduce cravings and you can mess
with it all day long so when it occurs
to you oh i gotta be doing something
that's how you quit man this company has
thousands of reviews from smokers who
have tried everything and nothing worked
for them until they tried fume
so thousands of five star reviews can't
be wrong and if it's bothering you that
you're
kind of
being looked at like a loser while
you're killing yourself with tobacco and
vaping
just
stop it man it's time to quit so go to
breathe fume dot com slash stevo and
you're gonna get 10 off your whole order
couldn't be a better time to do it
couldn't be a better deal for it so
breathfule.como
good luck and let's get into it
all right
was that a fly
no
ah joke come on hey okay all right
check check
wild ride episode number
what do we have to like 116.
do you remember what he was the last one
i did 100 i think no no i was 50. yeah
all right here we go
ladies and gentlemen danger aaron hello
everybody the return
so we've got you on tour yep we're here
in uh where are we wheeling west
virginia west virginia yep and last
night was your first time performing
comedy on stage in two years yeah i
haven't done a stand-up show or anything
live performance i don't think in about
two years yeah right and you you
prepared all new material some new
mostly all new material it's based on
you know a lot of the stuff from jackass
forever i brought some props with me and
uh crazy yeah that was awesome the
people really loved it and and you'd so
professionally set your timer to 12
minutes
your plan was to perform for 12 minutes
yup well that's what i was asked to do
and that's what i'll do and you went out
there and and and it seemed that every
joke you bro everywhere you were looking
for a laugh you gotta laugh i think so
and uh the crowd loved you they ate it
up yeah welcome back welcome back i
gotta say i i have so much fun
uh being on tour and and bringing in my
jackass buddies kind of one at a time so
just hang out do podcasts like film
content like do shows
and uh i think that the way you prepared
your material the way you executed it so
professionally i think that as uh
jackass openers go you might have
slipped right into the [ __ ] el numero
uno oh oh oh
oh
it's like the boys need to come back i
think step it up i think zac ass might
have the best actual joke at just the
one joke where he says you know so i got
into therapy and i was looking at these
apps and you know i found one called
better help and i thought well [ __ ] this
better help or i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
myself oh
jesus [ __ ] good joke oh man
he's doing great yeah
it's yeah like he's really giving it so
how is it out here for you how's it been
like what's going on i mean i just got
here yesterday i'm here for six shows
five days whatever yeah i mean
but you're out here grinding we go
pretty hard but we only go for the first
spurts you know we'll be out for like 10
days and then we'll go home and then we
go out for 10 days then we go home so
like it's not like we're on
tour for months or anything like that
but with that said man like
we're getting after it yeah and it's
crazy how
um
the the show
constantly
evolves and improves like uh yeah i saw
it like
three months ago in portland i think it
was
um and
they've you've had definitely added a
lot of material um like the intro and
stuff that yeah the opening sequence man
that i i'd love to get a final tally on
what we spent on the opening sequence
for the bucket list because it was
expensive yeah wow
helicopters and just [ __ ] well we
still have another shoot coming up on
the 20th we have another helicopter
shoot coming up happening yeah
epic dude yeah it sounds nice we don't
even use helicopters
in jackass i don't think we've we've
used the fake little ones
but i don't think we've ever used a
helicopter haven't i i've ever do issues
helicopters and wild boys all the time
but now speaking of jackass yeah you're
hands down the
the mvp of jackass forever i don't think
there's any debating that well thanks oh
my god like that anybody's seen that
movies like oh my god danger aaron and
the cup test and what you did to his
balls yeah
well when we went into filming i told
the guys i said hey i can't break my
neck again because i've done that three
times
and so i was thinking about other ways
to
you know use my body or and since we
when covid happened we could no longer
do man on the street stuff i have tons
of rad stuff written for like pranks and
man on the streets and all those just
went away instantly when covet hit so we
just focused on ourselves destroying
ourselves
and so i'm like i'm not gonna break my
neck
um
and actually about three oh yeah good
good call crack a little liquid death
refreshing sticks hey sticks
how are you doing out there sticks
one of my homies um
and so we just focused on like
destroying ourselves and i'm like i
can't destroy
my neck or my knees i've got 11 knees
i was like well
uh i was thinking i guess you know we'll
just focus on my dick um and come to
find out so like three weeks before
francis and god who punched me in the
balls in which was test number one which
was test number one
uh
i had uh already found out that i was
my like lindsay and i were were pregnant
we were having a child you kept that i
kept that a secret the whole time we
were filming because if you they know if
everyone knows i'm going to have a baby
already and i'm already sending it hard
on my dick they're going to just be like
well let's just rip it off right because
you've already used it in a sense you
know but i don't think i don't i don't
think i could i couldn't have done any
gnarlier though i don't think that would
have changed the outcome that i don't
think that sensitivity to your like
ability to procreate was really in the
equation
uh but dude i remember when i remember
showing up to the set like uh probably
the first week after we got back from a
corvette if not like the first day yeah
and uh and and i'm a humongous fan of
ufc and they're like dude francis inganu
the [ __ ] ufc heavyweight at the time
he was the number one contender now of
course he's the champion
he uh he's going to punch danger and
aaron and the balls for the cup test and
and i as soon as i heard that
i said please let me have this bit
please
let let
please let francis and garner punch me
in the balls oh my god what an honor
that would be so rad and they said um
they said no
you want it too much
whenever you want yeah it's like
i hate ice cream i'm ice cream
i love bee stings
we don't need to sting with any babies
exactly
but but okay let me ask you a question
they said that you had your neck issue
yeah they said you had your neck issue
they said knoxville had just had a like
a hernia surgery yeah
so he couldn't get
hit like that in the nether regions and
uh they just shut me down they're like
no and then as i came to learn that it
was francis and ganu and then it was
with the bowling okay so that let me ask
you
like i'm so glad i didn't [ __ ] yeah i
was gonna ask okay so my question to you
is okay the francis inganu bit happens
would you have wished you did that if it
had led into all the other things i did
no no i'm so like i said i'm so glad i
did not [ __ ] do that oh my god can i
ask a question how many times did they
attempt each like so francis punch was
three times the first time i flinched a
little second time i think he just held
back and punched me kind of in the
stomach and the third one was the nail
but like the softball test was i think
14 times and my legs yeah like
they used a lot of that like there's so
so many times when
things are shot over and over and over
and over and over and they only use one
time and that's like since the
heartbreaking i know it's like the like
when i did the hockey uh the hockey okay
so i think they used just about
everything hockey was so so i went from
francis to the softball fourteen times
blasted me looked like a lep like
cheetah print and then immediately after
that an hour later
because i i told jeff i was taking
softballer the same day yeah nice
because i i was in so much pain so
i'm like i don't want to sleep on it and
do it tomorrow let's just do it now and
they're like are you serious i'm like
yeah get dave let's let's use that pogo
stick let's go right over there and have
him just jump on my dick and
and then
we did that
twice
twice the first time
it it he missed like he it had my the
cup not been as big as it was i mean it
was soft though but it but it was much
bigger like surf surface area had he not
hit the cup and it went into my skin i
think it possibly could have went
through my body because if you think
about the energy of a pogo stick it
springs off of whatever it lands on so
it would have just compressed right
through my my skin right through my body
so are you sitting there with one ball
right now or did you know when he did
land it on on my on the cup right on my
nut it was on the right test to go and
it exploded the right testicle so then
it was bleeding and i had to rush to the
hospital then when i was there there's
you know i went and saw a specialist
like later on like two or three days
later and then i had to do follow-up
visits like every month for about four
months just to have them check to make
sure that the the
the testicle itself was healed because
if blood gets into the testicle it kills
all the sperm but i was already having a
kid so yeah
cedar
a little cedar moon so you're done
having kids i'm guessing no i'm cool i'm
sure i could have more dave only has one
dot and one nut david has four kids did
they test your sperm count after all
that when you're going to doctor for all
that no testing of sperm counts i'm just
you know fingers crossed i don't want to
know
yeah
so
i remember while we were filming jackass
forever and you were just getting all
this insane footage left and right and
i'm thinking oh my god dude like
danger's kind of gone under the radar
like in life you know
and now like you're gonna be like so
much more recognizable in the streets
has that happened
it it has i mean it's kind of always
been there and and you know like even
with like the the terror taxi you know
like this terror taxi bit like those
kinds of things people always know kind
of who i am and whatever but i don't i
don't do a lot of things like
putting me out into the public a lot
like i'm at home and doing my thing and
working on my life and touring with
bands shooting photos and when i'm out
people are like especially now people
are like [ __ ] we love you dude and it's
it's really cool
um
you know i i think there's obviously
strike why the iron's hot opportunity
when we put out a new film or a new
movie or something but
i i have a one-year-old and i'm way more
stoked on what i'm doing right now than
anything i don't regret or wish i was
doing anything else i'm raising a rad
little baby and we have a nice little
family and i'll get back to it someday
and uh
you're married not married but
i mean with covid and stuff like we
if we were gonna get married during
covet it would have been just kind of
lame you know like no party you know
anything so we're just waiting just kind
of she's going through uh nursing school
at ohsu and she's done with that in a
couple in like nine months how's your
relationship
oh
how is your relationship you know let me
tell you my relationship is going very
well in the bedroom for a lot of reasons
not the least of which is that my girl
and i sleep on a mattress from helix
sleep.com why are we so happy with it
because when you go to helix sleep.com
stevo you take a very simple two-minute
quiz to find your perfect mattress for
you and your partner and i'm telling you
best deal overall best mattress overall
best fit for you and
i'm willing to bet a lot of you guys
mattresses are pretty disgusting at this
point and it's time to get a freshie so
dude go to helixsleep.com
stevo and you'll get up to 200
off of any mattress you choose and when
you do so they're gonna throw in two
free pillows
i mean dude let's tighten up the bedroom
it's gonna help your relationship
whether or not you're in one so go to
helixsleep.com to get matched with the
perfect mattress for you you get up to
200 off of any mattress of your choosing
and they throw in two free pillows
that's because they love the listeners
of the wild ride podcast maybe more than
listeners of any podcast so support the
podcast and
help your relationship help your sleep
go to helixsleep.como
to get matched with the perfect mattress
for you and get a killer deal up to 200
off any mattress and two free pillows
there it is it's waiting for you at
helix sleep.com
stevo now let's talk about dangerous
relationship
it's um it's great but it's it's very up
and down like
i swear to god like i know a lot of
people that have gotten divorced or
broken up during coven sure like people
have their own lives in separate you
know they need to separate a bit but
with kova everyone's in the house all
day long 24 7. right and and what would
normally be like a two-year relationship
i think it's more of like a five-year
experience with that person and it and
it's and and it's
made it a lot you know very intense and
it covered put relationships to the test
to the test and i i was stoked that i i
felt
pretty strongly that my relationship
with lux just got better
and that happens too because then you
realize how much you really
like being with this person and even if
you don't like being with this necessary
person all the time it's the trust and
love that you have and then that bond
and that bubble that you're in becomes
like just so
safe and and makes you feel good you
know yeah i don't remember any like
problem from koben
crazy
well you're you're you're behind
yeah you're you're in a minority there
my friend because i can tell you like
most people they say to me like oh my
god i had no idea
they were like this and we're together
all the time
yeah but lux is cool with you like
camping for a week or you know yeah
you're on the road all the time dude so
it worked out so great because i got the
the van for podcasting you know the red
the red van i got that like right before
coveted yeah so you were just interested
so when covered hit i was sheltering in
place like on the [ __ ] mountain on
the beach in melbourne yeah everywhere i
was sheltering in place [ __ ] all over
yeah man um
so
we talked about it when when you were on
the podcast the first time which by the
way i think was just an epic episode
thank you i had a lot of fun yeah yeah
this is we're we're in the rv now which
is quite a bit bigger and it expands out
some more room it's nice yeah the the
the piece of [ __ ] rv masquerading as a
tour bus yeah and um we were talking
about how i really feel that you're like
you know of the jackass guys like
arguably the most well adjusted
like the most like real world like you
know you don't really identify as as
like a celebrity guy
your uh your livelihood comes from real
estate you've taken all of your money
and like wisely invested it and
properties and you manage all these
properties and stuff yeah um i mean
it's like any like
entertainer athlete or anything that
where you make some money and people
know who you are and when you know it's
awesome it's awesome but eventually
nothing lasts forever and you really got
to just take that opportunity to do the
best you can with it for your future
because life is long even though it's
short dude life is [ __ ] long again
it's like yeah i'm rule right now
but two or three years from now and
you're not ruling and no one's paying
you anything what is what do you have
left and you just gotta be thinking
about like you know goals in life where
you want to be five ten years from now
and actually visualize it like don't
just stumble around and be like whatever
happens to me
no make things happen like you gotta
work hard too like you work your ass off
but you're doing it because you you
enjoy doing this i mean i love it and i
think you just uh
shared the best life advice you you have
to have a goal if you're going to
accomplish a goal yeah if you don't if
you don't set a you know a goal for
yourself then you're never going to do
anything yeah and goals do change and
you can allow your goals to change and
don't say that you you didn't succeed
because you didn't reach the goal that
you had just right be realistic like you
know somebody could say i want to
you know i want a ferrari and then you
get a toyota but you know your goal then
is now you've got a toyota and you
should be happy with it right you know
lux's nephew who i like to call my
nephew yeah
um is now living with us taking care of
all of our animals at the house even
when we are home so there's just always
like
and a caretaker yeah a caretaker that's
great because we love having them around
and i told this kid he's what 19
i said like man we're gonna we're gonna
pay you every day to take care of our
animals whether we're home or not we
just i just don't want to have to worry
about yeah you know about anything and i
and i was like you know i'm gonna give
you my car so you got a free car you
know like uh
like you're uh yeah you're taking care
of the animals is like a half hour of
work a day
yeah an hour maybe on an aberrational
day so you've got your whole [ __ ] day
wide open
to to pursue your
your goals and we want to help open up
the world to you you know like so my
advice i told him i said figure out your
highest goal your most crazy ambition
what what you would love more than
anything in life in a dream world that
the best it could turn out and once
you've identified that as
something you want to work towards then
kind of walk it back and figure out
what's a good entry-level job that you
can realistically get which puts you the
closest to
that ultimate dream goal yeah land you
kind of at the periphery of that world
get on the bottom rung of the ladder
that leads up to that
that that [ __ ] dream position that
you want and start [ __ ] going getting
after it and if we can help you get on
that bottom rung we wanted like you know
yeah and we got this kid
the kid's just so stoked and he's such a
rad kid too that's the reality of life
though that that it being long is that
yeah i mean i i suffer from this as well
like i want to learn i want to know how
to do it now like a lot of times i want
to be able i want to be the best now but
it takes like years to be good at
something let alone the best or
something yeah
if you're planting seeds you can't
expect it to
be fruitful but people do and especially
today in society where like you can
strike it rich as a youtuber or
something and it's like and then all
these other people like i want to do
that too and it's like well right that's
like
you know some sort of panning for gold
and you you got gold and dudes who got
the gold
isn't any better at than the person who
happened to find the gold downstairs oh
no dude i think that the youtube the the
whole like digital influencer space like
that it's so democratic you know like
well if you're like if you're cool
you're cool and if you're not every
piece of content you put out is
essentially like a [ __ ] vote for for
like how well-received it is it's the
analytics are just so
[ __ ]
accurate and democratic that like i
really think you got to give credit to
people who who succeed with youtube
because they're getting something right
and there's no succeeding on youtube
unless you are tirelessly [ __ ]
motivated and working right but that's
the thing is like people see those
people doing these things think it's so
easy and it's nice well now there's like
twitch there's only fans there's people
[ __ ] putting their feet on websites
crushing it like six figures
there's a lot of opportunity out there
you know right but what i like about you
is that you got more specific with your
goals in the last like three months is
like you want to open the animal
signature yeah but now you want to
employ hundreds of people rescuing
thousands of animals and i think as like
you get more specific how do you start
that
but my friend my ultimate goal is to
employ hundreds of people to take care
of thousands of animals and my first
like legit employee whose only job is to
take care of animals
there you go there you go so you start
you're starting so you're starting at
the bottom there too then that's your
first
step to what you have goals and dreams
you have one employee and you've rescued
six animals oh my god dude we have
we technically have ten animals at the
house even though during the show i say
we have three cats three dogs three
goats and four pissed off neighbors wait
you have those
you have goats in your house in
hollywood there not inside the house we
have uh we've been waiting wait yeah we
built a little barn in the back
where is there even room for a little
bar
we predator-proofed the [ __ ] out of our
backyard because we don't want like
predators oh yeah you live in the hills
there and those like i was there that
one day
and you're when my cat got eaten by a
coyote right now
so so what we did to prevent
uh predators from digging underneath the
fence we built a [ __ ]
foot and a half concrete wall
underground around the entire [ __ ]
perimeter of backyard and then we built
up the the fences with with [ __ ] crazy
spikes so nothing's coming over yeah you
got goals you got goals dude predator
proofed the [ __ ] out of it yeah and uh
and we built a barn so we put the goats
up in the barn at night and they just
hang out in the backyard during the day
are the neighbors really like their
bombs
the
oh it's cute it's a cute sound it's not
too gnarly what's gnarly is the dogs
well particularly one dog
all night he gets stuck outside and he
can't move and he's like
just like
on a [ __ ] loop endlessly incessantly
and there's this one neighbor in
particular that that uh like is and the
nicest the nicest guy nicest couple but
they're just like for the love of god
please you know and then dude and then
and then i realized long uh after the
fact
that this guy i didn't recognize him
because his [ __ ] beard like growing
out so big like you know
he's
hands down
my favorite circus performer
oh really
yeah he's i don't want to give away his
identity but you live next to it if you
ask me
the last 20
plus years if there if i have one person
in mind who's the most talented
circus performer or performer period i
would say this guy wow and then it turns
out you didn't know that he was your
neighbor no i had no idea he's my
neighbor and he's the one guy who's most
terrorized by our [ __ ] answer oh god
he hates you
he probably loves you i mean he he's
he's down for me he said himself he's
like do i get it you know you you you
love animals you care about animals you
know it's just like [ __ ]
it's crazy you have a favorite circus
performer well dude 100
dude isaac who's my uh my guy on tour he
helps on tour a day i gave him the whole
[ __ ] walking through
like don't give it away because the best
footage of this guy
he's like dude his [ __ ] head exploded
dude that's all i could think about he's
like oh my god wow i love it dude yeah i
go i go crazy for that [ __ ] now i got
bugsy yeah that's that's this he's a
well-behaved dog yeah he's a he's dude
he just finds his way like right in your
arm yeah he sleeps in my arm all under
my arms [ __ ] i've ever seen he goes
everywhere with me all over the world
yeah danger bugsy
so okay so how many real estate
properties are you said nine no uh
i just acquired two more uh in the last
three months so i've seven
seven sold one bought two and uh and and
most of these are on mortgage yeah uh a
couple are paid off okay but uh most of
them are on mortgage especially the last
three years
even if they weren't on mortgage i would
i went and got loans for them because
money was so cheap you know two and a
half percent or three percent rates so
um everything's locked down 30-year
fixed we'll see what happens i you know
the markets
probably like it did in o8 go down but
if you're not selling then what's it
worth it's not worth anything less than
it was before right so you just hold on
long-term long game is 30-year plan you
know i've got a plan for each every
single one of them like how to sell them
when to sell them
you know depending on how i'm doing in
this business and whatnot like when
you're crushing it in hollywood and
you're making money you don't want to
sell your real estate because then you
you have to pay more in taxes right than
you already you already do so generally
the rule of the real estate is just
never sell yeah right ultimately put in
the trust give to the family peace
what was your situation in 2008 when uh
in 2008 i had five
properties
and that was just that was what you did
with your money from jackass one and two
damn yeah that's great when did three
come out no that was 10 so yeah so
from one and two uh i i uh
at five properties um i'd you know you
can
buy one as and and you can leverage off
of that if you have good credit and
whatever else and uh but then the market
tanked and everyone was like freaking
out like people were like offing
themselves and and it was a very
stressful time but scott [ __ ] got his
ass kicked you sold
i pulled out the the down payment on a
credit card and then bought it in 06 and
then a week later it dropped like 60
grand
i just let it go after three years yeah
i mean at a certain point and scott for
the first how many years we worked
together was like battling his way out
of debt three from years
every from like what so many people were
i mean that's the thing is like if it
happens again there's gonna be another
so many people and
earlier i i don't think it'll be
gnarlier uh i think it's it's gonna be
different i think everything affects
everything so like if you have like if
oil prices go up then food prices go up
then everything goes up and inflation
hits because we give away a bunch of
free money and don't
like and then now people are used to not
working to and not doing anything and
getting this money and then the money's
disappearing but they're like i still
don't want to go back to work like and
uh inflation's going up so i think
everything that you're describing
indicates that it's going to be gnarlier
when the [ __ ] hits the fan this night
well it's a worldwide phenomenon on this
one the one before was based on bad
credit which was given to people that
didn't have sub the right yeah it was
like stated income loans made it so that
people could just buy a house i bought a
house with a 520 credit score and stayed
at income and you just probably said
yeah
the guys like the guys like you have any
credit lines and i was like no he's like
can you go to like men's warehouse and
buy some socks on credit and then like
get you a line i'm like yeah i did that
he's like cool got you alone yeah seven
percent interest only yeah jesus okay
and you got any weed
he was like chewing in my ear on the
floor
yeah that was a different time yeah you
don't think it's gonna be the same thing
like what do you think's gonna crash
first if it hasn't already i think i
think that because interest rates
auto loans well hot over prices are up
higher than they've ever been in the
history of new cars new cars because of
the supply chain supply chain and
inflation like everything's more like
like uh contractors if you hired a
contractor that was 65 bucks an hour
three years ago he's 125 now and the
materials that they're using like the
wood and metal and everything that's
tripled
so that means that home prices go up
because it costs more right but but
we were up in uh in portland oregon on
seaside oregon uh yeah you were like
talking about yeah yeah the oregon
you were like
with your own bare hands like [ __ ]
you're like a contractor too yeah i do
most of my own construction on my own
properties with with licensed
contractors and stuff when needed but
for the most part like i i've learned
how to do most of my own contracting and
what you did with your how your main
house in portland was unbelievable yeah
i did landscaping
the deck
it's a lot of work and that's the thing
like like i always think back to when
people like from goonies remember chunk
and everyone's like sure what happened
to jesus
he's an entertainment lawyer he's
killing it more than he would have
probably had he stayed in the hollywood
business in the sense of acting and
people think he died you're like oh that
guy died he had to because he was
killing it and then he disappeared but
you disappeared from hollywood in the
entertainment industry doesn't mean you
died you can have a life and there's
like
normal people like like doing real lives
that have been in movies before and
how many people
uh are you a landlord to
um i have a couple vacation rental
houses so
those constantly are being uh that's not
so bad like i i think of landlord and
i'm like [ __ ] man i don't
i would never be able to like yeah i
don't want somebody you couldn't do it
here's one thing i've always bought my
real estate on base the premises
premise of and that is do i would i want
to live here so if the market tanked i
lost everything if this was a place that
i had to live and could afford it would
i want to live here and if i say no then
why would i want to buy it you can buy
it to make money and some people
approach the real estate
game as just monopoly let's make money
money money but i do it in a different
way where i really have a connection to
oregon i'm from there fourth generation
like i love it so much i want to be able
to invest as much into the place i love
most and i've had opportunities to buy
other places and make money but i just
didn't because i didn't want to live
there if i had to so i just buy places
where if i need to live there or move
there or want to like own it for the
rest of my life or and pass it down to
my daughter or something i think it's
you know that's the way i buy stuff i do
it
ultimately in in the end
i don't want to lose money but i'm doing
it more for for multiple reasons there's
tax implications you know all these
things there's like there's so many
benef good benefits to owning real
estate um
it is tough because when you're doing
real estate in the moment like a
toilet's broken you got to fix it like
with the stock market when it goes down
you just don't look at it just ah you
just avoid it when it comes back up and
you're like yeah i'm winning and then
when you're losing but when a toilet
breaks you're you can't be like i'm just
gonna ignore it because then there's
[ __ ] flying all over the place and then
that causes your floors to rot and then
next thing you know your foundation's
broken and
so real estate
is a constant hands-on game right and
that takes a lot of time and it takes
away from the time that would be spent
doing
more entertaining and whatnot but you
know that's why i'm stoked to be out
here for a week because it's for sure
it's fun to get out and you know
challenge myself like i i was literally
like i don't know
i think you guys you guys were doing
like uh
like
five of you with like
pontius and preston and dave and you
yeah man like you had like a couple
tours yeah we did a canada tour right
now would be the best time for you guys
to do that again like you know i got all
you guys coming out with me like like
working on your axe yeah dave came out
with you i think i talked to wee man he
said he's gonna try to come out with you
this fall yeah yeah absolutely and
preston i mean you guys each have like
15 minutes at least yeah like there's an
hour and twenty years
like at the end of my shows i i say hey
you know like now that the show's over
if i can get everyone pull out your
phone and take a photo you know so that
they've got something to post yeah
and like when i've got you guys when
i've got one of you guys it's just
really rad
like to see the the feedback man we got
to we went to the stevo show it was
great and [ __ ] you know dan's danger
was a surprise guest it was awesome yeah
i mean that must be rad for you too like
i'm here for a week dave was here for a
week yeah preston's here for a week we
went to prince he was with us well he
was here yeah
he started out driving dude he told me
he was driving
all night
30 seconds of him driving he broke the
trailer
preston is a wild man and he drives like
a wild man what can i say but we loved
having him on the bus every day you know
what i do on the tour bus every day i
start by
getting hydrated with a pint of water
and i pour into it a serving of athletic
greens this is the most comprehensive
convenient and delicious daily nutrition
supplement that you can get it's
absolutely tasty i look forward to it
every morning and it fills in all the
gaps in my diet it helps me with my gut
health it helps me with my cognitive
ability because it's good for my brain
and why because it's loaded with 75
different vitamins minerals whole
food-sourced superfoods
probiotics adaptogens it's like the
healthiest stuff out there and
i love it i love it every day and you're
going to love it too i'm sure because
it's just so good for you and it's so
delicious and if you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo
then you're gonna get an entire year's
supply of immune supporting vitamin d
you're gonna get five of these daily
ag-1 packets which is your comprehensive
convenient nutrition for the whole day
and you're gonna get that free with your
first order if you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo you'd be crazy not to because
i've got a feeling you could be a lot
healthier and i'm a lot healthier
because of it so get over to
athleticgreens.com
jump on this deal and
let's get back to it
you're coming out of a dip no no no no
you've been the first for 30 seconds
like
that was when we were actually getting
centered like we tried to bring
the [ __ ] bus to to go to a shop to
dude [ __ ] he's doing errors
it's like he's trying to [ __ ] jump
really he's like he's trying to turn it
like it's a monster
because he's a semi-truck driver so yeah
but yeah it's rad i love having you guys
come out yeah um now i remember when we
were doing shows together like because i
kind of started that thing
when when you would be performing you
would say about how you had stopped
drinking yeah you were drinking you
would drink a duels all the time yeah um
so i haven't drank alcohol i i started
drinking wine again about two years ago
that's alcohol it is it is
wait what yeah no it's not it's great
you're portland it's so big it's grapes
you're wrong there's grapes
it's fermented grapes
fermented grapes
and alcohol
i would do coke yeah
maintenance
oh man you can come up with these all
day long
no but i haven't drank beer nine years
or eight years i haven't had any like
whiskey
drinking alcohol
what was it that made you stop drinking
in the first place
so i stopped drinking all together
everything for six years um and because
you had an issue with alcohol well
here's the thing is
doing like what we've done for so long
like we got paid to party we we drank
every day was a part of what we did
and then i got to the point where when i
stopped i actually just basically had a
like i would say like some sort of like
mental breakdown where i lost
my
my mind like i i think something i
remember i think i remember and you were
telling me i have a problem with alcohol
well it wasn't a problem with alcohol it
was the see i was a functioning per i
was what you could consider a
functioning alcoholic i'd have i'd be on
tour with bands you know shooting photos
and doing my thing and i
i could do i could have like five five
to ten jack and cokes every night ten
jack and cokes every night like
whatever no big deal and i would perform
i could do my stuff but every day i woke
up and i had this like just dehydrated
feeling and my body was you know all the
voices in your head were
cranked up i got to the point where it
was groundhog's day and i felt no hope
for
for no
way out and
i literally lost it where i took myself
to the emergency room and i said i
because i
something in my brain kind of just like
had enough in it
i went like a little psychosis and then
um you know they wanted to to
help me there and put me in a you know
a place where they like the same asylum
i guess it would be considered um and i
said
no uh i'm gonna take care of this myself
and that day
i stopped drinking i stopped drinking it
all together i hadn't drank since that
time for six years and and it was to the
point at which i
really don't think i could have survived
if i didn't because i was so depressed
because i just felt
so hopeless so no way out no way out
today you know when you wake up and
you're like oh i'm so hungover i'm never
drinking again and then now you're
drinking again and then i'm so
and when you get in that cycle with
whatever it is you're doing and there's
just that idea of nothing's gonna change
and there's no hope
you literally like i snapped i lost it
and and that is what cured me is that i
realized
that i
the only person that will do this the
only person that can fix this is me like
and then and there's people that can
help along the way for sure i believe
that but it comes down to you you're
you're with yourself 24 7. you know what
you've dreamed you know what your
visions are your goals you know when
you're doing wrong and if every morning
you wake up thinking i did it again it
just doesn't give you a chance to have a
good day
i mean
i think that the definition of
alcoholism is when you are
genuinely powerless to stop and you know
it sounds like you were a problem
drinker and you found a a a real
reason to
to to stop or or moderate and you were
able to do so and and that's great yeah
like that there's like a level of
alcoholism where no amount of willpower
can ever help you but it's but it's but
the thing is so weird is that i wasn't a
problem drinker and that's the i think
the worst alcoholic or person who drinks
alcohol does any kind of drugs or
anything the substances are those that
can function with it for no no oh my god
absolutely bottom drunk because well no
no i mean here's the thing it just never
stopped i i was the luckiest because you
were just i was like
because for me it was so goddamn bad
that it had to stop and because it had
to stop i'd surrendered to the process
of recovery and and and got better yeah
and when you surrender to the process of
recovery like when you treat alcoholism
you somehow become a better version of
yourself than you were before you
suffered from it yeah and the worst
situation is when you have alcoholism
slash addiction but not so bad because
it's not so bad it doesn't absolutely
have to stop yeah and it never does stop
and the years slipped through your baby
and you're dead
yours turned into decades slipping
through your fingers and then you turn
around you're like what the [ __ ] did i
do with my life i blew it yeah did you
ever have you ever done so many
psychedelics you thought you're never
coming back i can tell you you i bro you
you i mean it took you years to come
back yeah okay you weren't you now who
you are or before for
four years dude probably after when you
when you finally went to do this right
to sober living in rehab and
i mean dude how many times do you
remember going to india and we're
sitting next to each other on the plane
and i was telling you this i'm like bro
you're a good dude like you you have so
much you're you're blowing it you're you
don't even know who your name right now
and you're like [ __ ] yeah
but then but then when you got to that
point at which you got to help and you
went through the process do you still
for like three or four years we're still
kind of like this in-between guy it was
like
check this out when uh
like
i was in
treatment i was like rehabs and psych
wards for six months okay and um
when i got at the end of that six months
i moved into a sober living yeah right
so then so once i got out of the six
months and into the sober living then i
was sort of free to go to go around and
i went and and uh spoke
at the um salvation army where all these
people the most low bottom
like alcoholics and addicts are in rehab
which is free and it's just like the
most like kind of dingiest place where
you can get better this is the low
bottom people and i'm there like
carrying the message telling my story of
recovery six months sober
and uh
yeah i thought it was fine and then
three months later now i'm nine months
sober i go back
and uh
and they they're some of the guys are
still there they're like dude steve oh
man we've
we were here when you're here like we
were worried about you yeah yeah they
were worried about your sober dude if
you could have seen yourself bro i'm
telling you for like for quite some time
yeah you were lower than those dudes
that you're saying are low like [ __ ]
like you were
like like what yeah
just like just not even human like i
don't even like i don't know
like steve what was the first thing you
bought with like your money he's like oh
dude like a refrigerator full of vodka
and budweiser it wasn't the first thing
but but uh i bought a house and you
bought a fridge with bubblegum
it was actually pretty pretty uh
shortly before i got sober one of the
last things i bought was a [ __ ] huge
full tall sized fridge that had the like
that the left side was like freezer from
top to bottom one door
you know there's equal space for the
freezer vodka and beer so the freezer
was full you couldn't fill another
bottle of vodka into it from top to
bottom
and then and then the right side was the
fridge and you couldn't fit enough was
that the apartment the skate apartment
that was in
[ __ ] fountain that was in my office
apartment oh i had the the skate park
apartment the office department was in
that building
and the assistant apartment what was
your vodka of choice when you drank like
that [ __ ] i think it was grey goose in
there the whole thing so grigoose and
budweiser grey goose and budweiser's yes
wow it's [ __ ] dirty i mean see but
that you you that that you can recognize
as a problem like and that's like you
when you hit rock bottom or multiple
times hit rock bottom
you it's like everyone around you now is
like saying you have a problem but when
you're just floating through
and everyone's like oh he's cool yeah
right now
being sober if you do something wrong
like you're bummed about it you make it
right later but like when you were [ __ ]
when you were [ __ ] up was there any of
that like feeling bad like [ __ ] i got to
make it right with this person or was it
he didn't feel bad for anything
if anything he felt better feeling bad
like he like would make people feel like
[ __ ] and love it
i don't know that i would love it
i don't know you were pretty stoked
every time you did something [ __ ] up
like i think
yeah
i definitely became capable of being
pretty pretty mean-spirited yeah and
trying to hurt people's feelings and
like harm their reputations like i did
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
ultimately that's what got me sober more
than anything was because i became so
[ __ ] ashamed of of all that [ __ ] that
i had done i just like never wanted to
be that person again and so that like
motivated me to really dive in to
everything that people do but like what
we're talking about right now and you've
you asked me like how did i stop
drinking when i stopped and yeah i drink
wine now but i'm responsible in whatever
portland
yeah i'm important silver or sonoma
sober can we get a shirt made this is
portland sober yeah with a
but the thing is is like
every person
i don't care how
down you are how [ __ ] up you are you
have that opportunity to make a choice
any every day today tomorrow you do it's
life's not over you have that choice
dude and if you start today listen you
know it's real if you start today and
live for the future and just
don't live from for what you had didn't
do in the past or what you've been doing
and you just start over start over like
today is my new life
i think it's possible that everybody can
get better and clean up like whatever
their problems they have isn't it i mean
like it doesn't really
translate to alcoholism and drug
addiction because
we've had millions upon millions of
people come before us and show that like
really there's only one way to to to
treat that and it's you can't do it
alone you got to do it as a collective
as a group
i stopped drinking cold turkey
but then that just means that you are
like uh
you know not really i think we all have
that ability i really do everybody has
an ability to turn their life around and
i think it's as [ __ ] up as you are
that's the exact opposite is true of how
[ __ ] rad you can get yeah you know
what i mean and it's usually the people
that are the
worst becoming coolest yeah so when when
that when you're drinking your own duels
yeah like back in the day
like every every time i saw you get on
stage like years ago yeah you would uh
carve the glass bottle with the diamond
in your tooth yeah right there yeah like
it didn't when it just puts a scratch in
the bottle i mean i can cut through a
[ __ ] wall of glass dude like i can
actually cut through glass because your
tooth is diamond it's got a black
diamond in it yeah uh it's platinum with
this is the tooth that i pulled out with
bam's lamborghini broke my face to my
eyeball took six months to heal nine
months to heal it would have kept going
all the way up to my skull but luckily
my eye socket was there to stop it but
but i so i put a black diamond in and
then my whole
thought was that in case i ever get
stuck in a glass cube somewhere like you
guys put me in something i don't know
whatever
it's it's a tool i can cut through glass
so yeah i show everyone i can cut glass
now how much is that tooth worth
this is my rock bottom dude when i hit
rock bottom i'm coming i'm gonna hawk
this thing and i'm coming back baby was
it it's an over ten thousand dollar
tooth no i mean but with all the
inflation yeah with inflation it's
probably about ten wow is uh is it in
there with the dental implant yeah they
because it ripped my brood all the way
out and cracked my face so they had to
take somebody else's bone yeah bone
graft and bone graft it and then put a
post in there and then
put that so it's attached into my face
is bone graft not the worst [ __ ]
surgery like
the worst surgery is root canal like
i've ever had a root canal i've had tons
of root canals i i felt like that
because root canals usually are infected
by the time you get it and it's like
brutal but the bone graft did suck and
then you have to be very careful forever
and you can't do anything crazy
mouth but
so
we we talked about how you have had like
27 different surgeries yeah
like what like what what's your uh your
physical
like state like right now like getting
out of bed in the morning like
for
for quite some time now it's been very
difficult to get out of bed um i've been
working really hard with this
chiropractor
and some a couple of different people in
in oregon up in portland um and also
myself just getting to the gym or you
know laying on some rollers
i do stretch i i i want to stretch more
i don't think you can ever over stretch
so but stretching like like with
with injuries
you get scar tissue and the scar tissue
just basically makes it so your muscles
don't can't work and so you got to get
all that inflammation out
um and so
i've been working really hard but yeah i
know i mean 11 knee surgeries three
broken necks i mean there's
it's it's it's [ __ ] real dude
arthritis and all of these things when
you get older and you know i just had a
birthday and lux got me a a massage at
like just some massage envy place yeah
and and the this dude was doing my
massage and he's like man like
you uh
he's like we're gonna need to not even
bother with a massage right now and i'm
just going to help you stretch yeah
are you feeling how are you feeling i
feel pretty good i just have like i just
need to stretch is really what it is
what about your neck though you went and
did yeah i did the stuff did that work
stem cell um i mean does it like i'm i'm
looking at doing it down in uh columbia
um maybe down in mexico at this place a
stem cell thing i mean i don't know but
i
i've heard mixed reviews i i i always
say man like people ask me so much that
i just what i was doing was was largely
preemptive i wasn't in like real pain i
don't don't have like range of motion
problems like i just have to this
degenerative disc disease which
poses a threat to me in the future and
so i was kind of preemptive so i'm not a
good like
yeah like dude what did danny say danny
wave [ __ ] swears by it cool chuck
liddell
the guys who are in the worst shape that
like
that's the thing is like i'm so far i
like when i do do things that
help me
the person that's doing those things
like it's a i'm a good gauge to be able
to say like if it helps me it will help
you i mean dude like they the place down
in colombia
loves having people there who can uh
draw attention to what they're doing
yeah and and you're a prime candidate
yeah i have to get all of them maybe go
down to colombia for multiple reasons
yeah
i'm just kidding
i've never done coke in my life never
once right really i've never even tried
it not even one time in my life did i
ever offer it to you all the time you
did i you you wanted to snort coke off
my butthole i think at one point why
didn't you ever accept it i just don't
do coke if he would have said i'll smoke
no i'm kidding but i did smoke weed off
out of his ass i i wouldn't yeah i
wouldn't have
like i've always been pretty good like i
wouldn't if someone doesn't smoke
cigarettes i wouldn't give them their
first cigarette like i still i won't
give anyone their first tattoo yeah no
way i would have wanted to give you your
first line of code no i mean it
those were different times man i swear
to god like we were all
everyone back then
god it's hot uh yeah we were all we were
all just
wild like you know
yeah now like we've got you know younger
the the the the new crew of jackass and
yeah dude this is
they cannot
do what we did back then because what we
did back then was us doing it now times
are different and you you like you can't
really
you can come in with us and hang out
with us but let's not try to recreate
with the things that we used to do
because those things aren't doable
anymore right well especially because
like here we we
cut bam loose because he was like you
know
still doing what we used to do yeah and
now like you can't bring in new guys to
do that no
i mean in the end in the end let's be
real like this is a business and we we
have characters in which we play sure
but outside of what we do on jackass it
doesn't have to be like 24 7 365. we're
not i'm not a jackass i i i used to be
like that though and dude is there
anything scarier than than the idea of
being famous and broke no like literally
probably the scariest thing it's not
to be fair and the only thing gnarlier
than to be famous and broke is to be
famous for a bad reason and
because then people hate you
and you can't get away from anybody
because you're broke so you're just
basically out there and everyone assumes
the minute you become famous or on
television that you're rich i'm like
that's not real like what's real is like
bills have to be paid and just because
you were on tv or a show or a movie or
something doesn't mean that you're rich
and so there are a lot of people who are
who are famous and broke like they they
would like shock you yeah you know but
how could that person not be [ __ ]
killing it and it's just so weird
because like with having the new guys on
jackass and and you know the new girl
like
you cannot fault jackass for
for not giving them like tons of money
because the reality is people would line
up around the entire [ __ ] world
to be in a jackass movie for free you
know like it's like you're handing them
a humongous opportunity by inviting them
to be a part of jackass and you really
don't have to pay them a ton of money to
do it but on the flip side of that when
we get these new people in the jackass
movie we've essentially put them on this
huge platform made them into legitimate
celebrities and now
they're in this terrifying [ __ ]
position where they really are not
financially secure we weren't either
right like we were right you know that's
90 percent true
we didn't get paid that we're yeah let's
be honest but you know we did what we
did and you look back now like you know
like you said like you know aaron you
have all this real estate i'm like
i bought with the money i made on the
first jackass movie which was like
five thousand dollars or something and
you got a loan i got loan i got a loan
right then i did it with them
no no no
you don't feel bad one bit it's like
dude you can make dude if you had if you
you can dude you could become a
millionaire off of ten thousand dollars
like you can do anything it's not money
that's gonna get you there like be
creative like it does help to have money
obviously and and people might say well
you you you know you're you had an
opportunity and like yeah right plenty
of people have opportunities and still
blow it and many people don't have
opportunity and make it
so i remember when we were filming the
tv show there was like i was so 400
bucks a skit dude i was dude i got 100 i
got 200 bucks if it was a prank yeah
they're like a gag and 500 bucks if it
was like [ __ ] life
yeah no doubt like and then and then
sometimes at the first i think the first
season it was that if it didn't air you
didn't get paid
and then after that it changed
yeah after that second season it was per
episode yeah um but dude when we were
filming that first season i was so
[ __ ] broke dead broke because of all
my money whenever i got money i owed it
to the cocaine dealer oh god and so like
well you had credit with the cocaine
dealer yeah dude
i i i had credit whenever i got paid i
had to [ __ ] buy the coke i already
[ __ ] did
but uh
i'm um
we're filming this we're going to like
some [ __ ] fast food place to eat or
you know and i'm like hey uh
you know like can you guys [ __ ] you
know get me like a [ __ ] happy meal or
something you know
and they said to me they said to be like
you didn't get any footage today
oh
my god
you didn't get any footage today yeah so
you haven't you're out working so we'll
get you a soda water yeah i mean dude we
will not feed you because you didn't get
any footage today was this last week
maybe that would motivate you to step up
and get some [ __ ] footage tomorrow
it's a rough business dude
hollywood or like this is a rough
business you make such a valid point
because we got paid nothing yeah we were
[ __ ] big stars yeah instantly just
yeah so i mean anybody that's making
like a big chunk of change especially
all at once you have the opportunity to
invest it or do something to then
further that money to
and if and if you and if you make a
a a choice that you think is a a good
choice and and and it turns out being
wrong well at least you thought it was a
good idea like legit you and you thought
it through and it's like
you know
sometimes sometimes bitcoin bitcoin goes
down to twenty thousand dollars yeah
let's just be real
okay
i was like man i was just buying
gold uh at 19 20 an ounce and now it's
like 1704 and danger goes well at least
you didn't buy bitcoin at 60 000.
let me tell you this crazy story yeah
that i i had poopies on the podcast yeah
and uh it was just like completely
candid he says my bank account is a
negative number okay i'm like beyond
broke like you know and uh we had much
this similar conversation and it was
uncontroversial but then
uh my buddy burke kreicher huge comedian
he's got this huge i want to go on his
show i he said he was talking about me
and saying some stuff about the cup test
he loved it
i'd love to see bert if you're out there
dude i got you steve's guide me all
right i got you
so i'm buddies with bert kreischer and
he and uh tom segura another huge
comedian they did this podcast together
two bears in one cave they just cold
called me because they were raving about
how much they loved the jackass movie
and the new guys yeah i listened to that
one so they they called call me i'm like
you know like not just caught off guard
i'm like oh yeah and then they're like
we love the new guys and i was like yeah
dude who doesn't love the new guys and
get this i just had poopies on my
podcast says he's completely [ __ ]
broke can't even put gas in his car you
know and it was just like whatever you
know like i wasn't seeing it in any kind
of uh you know disparaging way or like
trying to shame anybody it's just like
crazy because here he's this [ __ ]
movie star now but that's the reality of
hollywood like i was saying it's like
just because you made it on a show or
something it doesn't mean you're right
i didn't think anything of it then when
that podcast came out well uh one of our
buddies and i won't like name them to uh
you know give him any grief but but i
got this text from one of our buddies
not a cast member but someone someone in
our world says what what are you doing
going on this big podcast and airing out
people's financial things he's like but
it's just [ __ ] tacky and it's like
and i was lazy he's like he says we're
the point you know in our lives and our
careers where we're supposed to be
bringing people up not pushing them down
and i was like but you're not making fun
of history
you're trying to like help him along
right exactly and i mean it is kind of
like
my response was
dude what i was like i wasn't doing that
and i wasn't trying to push anybody down
if anything i was trying to like you
know get a story there you know humanize
and help you know like
galvanize people in in in support of him
you know
and uh and it was so crazy because um
then i i hear from this guy steve will
do or no i hear from poopies himself
because dude steve will do it reach out
to me this is so crazy and and i hit up
steve will do it saying man you hit up
poopies dude that was so cool and steve
will do it says to me
dude i heard you on two bears one cave
man and like couldn't believe it poopies
didn't want to couldn't put gas in his
graves like i just want to do anything i
can to help him so [ __ ] that is why
poopies was just water skiing behind a
goddamn helicopter with steve williams
he was like the biggest guy on [ __ ]
youtube you know i ca i i love knocking
on the industry and saying you suck here
right right
let's be real you can't fall but there's
multiple there's a lot of us sure and
there's like you know in the days 10 of
us or whatever and and we're all the
stars like and so
with jackass it's it's hard but it's
that way with the whole industry it's
like how can i use you the most
all the world's a business everybody's
trying to [ __ ] get it really there's
other industries that people take care
of each other and respect each other and
love being able to see that other person
succeed whereas in this industry it
feels like
unless you're succeeding yourself then
it doesn't mean anything to you because
everyone's
very vain like everyone wants to be
the number one in this industry for sure
and and so it's very hard to have like
trust and and care like
in that to trust other people and what
they say and you'll just do whatever
like in that moment like it's like look
at us we were doing it for 400 bucks
because we were on mtv and 400 bucks was
400 bucks right but looking back now
like we should have got paid a hell of a
lot more they syndicated that stuff day
one like they're made they've made
hundreds of millions on the tv show
still cranking still cranking just try
to you know think about life as a long
it's a long long game like don't think
of for sure life being tonight's ripping
party
just remember try and get a plan come
put it together be a good person it'll
all work out in the end and if it
doesn't like work out the way you wanted
it to or the way you
dreamed it just find new dreams find new
goals and never give up and keep going
you know
why their words were never spoken man
time [ __ ] love you die let's go do
some comedy yeah
[Laughter]
yeah dude so there you have it and
i'm i want to address this change in
uh
title format
for the longest time
we've been
the number of the episode the name of
the guest boom just like that but we
noticed
all these other podcasts giving the
episode a title
and we said screw it let's give it a
shot
and when we were saying what are we
going to call the danger
danger aaron's second episode uh the
gorgeous paul briskey suggested
what about uh danger aaron has no pity
for the new jug now that is a catchy
salacious title and clearly that's
that's what he said he said hey man we
were in the same spot big whoop right so
let's just be clear it's not like
anybody wants to be pitied
[ __ ] pity right and
danger aaron and i both have a lot of
love right we may not have pity we got a
lot of love yeah dude thanks for
sticking around